I'm Amazed by what you've accomplished
the thing is yes you're a hot check
there's no question and you are willing
to be in bikinis and all that and that
brings in a certain amount of guys but
in order to get five million followers
you got to do more than just be the girl
in the Bikini you've got to open up your
whole life to people that's the secret
right yeah did you know that when you
started doing this so I started on Tick
Tock my freshman year of college I'm a
senior now this past summer I've been on
Tech talk all four years and when I
started out I had no idea and I was
trying to be picture perfect and I
thought that was the way to go and then
it honestly was the summer when I was at
probably like my lowest point I was
dealing with a bunch of acne and I
started posting about my acne and I was
like well I guess like this is so bad if
I post this and I can help someone feel
better about this and then people were
like oh like she's cool so so you are
three years into your Tick Tock and then
you got hit with bad acne yeah what
would you call it really bad acne yeah
like cystic acne face neck it was
everywhere then I posted about it and
then the followers started to come in
because they were like oh I guess like
she's like normal or whatever deals with
stuff too so it wasn't the hot chick
factor that got you into a lot of
followers it was the relatable factor
that you were willing to talk about that
you had problems that you weren't
perfect which is crazy because I was
trying for the opposite for three years
and then the second I stopped trying to
be the hot pretty picture-perfect girl
is when things started to take off and
how long does it take you to make the
decision I'm gonna put it out there I
had a brand video do yeah and my manager
is like okay Alex like time to send in
the video and I was like I cannot do it
my acne is so bad like I can't post it
and then I was like wait what kind of
like message am I sending out here and
it was so scary the first video I posted
with like my skin like raw no makeup I
watched it I refreshed it for like 30
minutes I was like oh my gosh people are
going to say mean mean things and then
it was just overwhelmingly nice positive
supportive community
foreign